the high level what this whole program
will be about very default Thanks
okay so yeah so foundations of data
science so data science is a term that I
can't tell term to describe say the
intersection of applied mathematics
statistics and computer science and some
of the goals of this program are to
bring together researchers working on
the algorithmic mathematical and
statistical foundations of data science
and we have emphasis on the following
topics dimensionality reduction
numerical linear algebra optimization
probability in high dimensions sparse
recovery compressed sensing statistics
inference in causality and robust
statistics streaming and sub linear time
algorithms and the goal is to strengthen
connections between these areas and to
get different people to talk to the
killer okay so a lot of different
communities are working on these
problems from different perspectives and
we'd like to understand the important
problems and the assumptions being made
in these communities so let me give you
a rundown of the of the bootcamp
schedule so the goal of the bootcamp is
to provide a sequence of tutorials to
get everyone up to speed on the
techniques used in this area so the
first talk will be given by Ravi Kannan
from Microsoft Research so he'll give an
overview he'll you know based on his
foundation the biggest science book it's
a great book he'll give an overview on
techniques such as high dimensional
geometry concentration inequalities
Gaussian densities and mixtures singular
value decomposition Markov chains rapid
mixing streaming algorithms and some
randomized algorithms for matrices so
he'll give the first two talks this
morning then I'll give the next two
talks this afternoon on dimensionality
reduction to obtain fast algorithms for
linear algebra problems things like
regression low-rank approximation robust
variants clustering tensor problems etc
tomorrow Ken Clarkson from IBM will
continue
men shouting reduction you'll look at
important sampling for different objects
and particular things like subspaces
where you use leverage core sampling
he'll discuss this and connections to
other fast dimensionality reduction
techniques like the subsampled
randomized Hadamard transform following
those talks Rachel Ward from UT Austin
is going to give us a tutorial on
first-order stochastic optimization so
she's going to cover stochastic gradient
descent applications to deep learning
importance sampling to improve
convergence and there many different
parameters in this landscape she'll talk
about things like adaptively choosing
step sizes etc then we'll have Michael
Mahoney who's here from UC Berkeley talk
about leverage core sampling again he'll
try to connect two different talks so
Ken's talk on leverage core sampling for
dimensionality reduction fast algorithms
in linear algebra so those guarantees of
leverage square sampling of quite a bit
different than those used for say
important sampling in stochastic
optimization so it also tie in well with
Rachel's talks so he'll give you no
trade-offs between those and then we'll
have Fred Brewster from University of
Queensland talk about second order
optimization methods and stochastic
variants okay so we fish in Newton type
algorithms for convex and non convex
optimization and a comparison between
first and second order methods next
we'll move into a more statistical
flavor of talks so we'll 50 and here at
Berkeley will give the first talk on
statistical inference and you can look
at this as a crash course in theoretical
statistics so he'll talk about things
like estimation hypothesis testing
confidence intervals from a frequentist
perspective Bayesian inference and some
possible asymptotics so that will kind
of set the stage for two remaining talks
so Santosh Kampala from Georgia Tech
will talk about high dimensional
the nominal for instance distribution of
mass law concavity extremal properties
different versions of your XP theorem
concentration of measure and
isoparametric inequalities following
that Elias Tyco Nikolas from USC is
going to talk about robust statistics
okay so there's a lot of exciting work
both by Santosh and Elias and others on
obtaining very efficient algorithms for
mean estimation and covariance
estimation of a Gaussian distribution
with in the presence of extreme outliers
there are some of possible methods that
do this nany fish in efficiently and
very recent accretion methods
finally on the last day I will have two
more tutorials one by Ilya resin Stein
from Mica's Microsoft Research he'll
talk about nearest neighbors so a lot of
recent exciting developments there in
high dimensions so you'll first give an
overview of locality sensitive hashing
or LSH and then move on to some of the
provably better algorithms based on data
dependent hashing that'll be the first
part of his talk in the second part
they'll talk about a very recent
exciting work on extending this to
non-euclidean geometries and finally the
last tutorial be given by michael
capital of from epfl who will talk about
the data stream model so this is a model
for processing the massive amounts of
data with low memory and one very
high-speed algorithms so he will be
talking about problems such as
estimating statistical moments finding
frequent items algorithms for mining
graphs in history and so that's all
let's let's go ahead and get started
Robbie he'll give the first talk thanks
everyone for coming
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
well thank you all for coming I should
start by saying in every organizational
organization committee somebody gets a
little bit of a free ride and somebody
who does a lot of work I'm an example of
the former I must thank David for being
the latter he is put in enormous amount
of work so thanks to him now when we
were discussing the boot camp the
meaning of the word boot camp is that
you present basics that cover a lot of
stuff we sort of decided to stick to
that definition a fair bit we'll have
some new results especially my talk will
be really basics it's not my intention I
mean this is not a research talk so it's
laying the grounds for other talks were
setting this tone and language and so on
so forth but I do hope I mean a lot of
you are of course going to be experts
and we'll know a lot of this stuff but I
do hope you see at least a few new ways
of looking at things not new maybe
unusual they are all classically really
but unusual ways of looking at things
perhaps but it will be familiar to all
of you and if I bore some of you that
I'm achieving my aim so pollination is
really science recap of the basics first
I'm going to start with concentration
inequality I mean good old concentration
inequality except I hope you'll see
something slightly unusual here again
not new I mean this is just a
pedagogical value a lot of this is from
a joint book I'm writing with John
Hawkes rough Navarone Blum is
downloadable from John Hawkes web page
so this proof is not there but otherwise
many things are there so first let's
look at some two independent random
variables which means they're all just
we want to show that the sum X oh I
didn't say that they expose or some I
should have some X is concentrated
around the mean right and Hosting
channel which we use a lot of course the
first step is to say that probably the
excavated and a is less than or equal to
the expected value of e to the lambda X
minus a for any positive lambda so
moment generating from
that's good and it gives you very
elegant proofs because this is a nice
function so you upper bound that these
are what you might call exponential
moments as a function of lambda and then
take the minimizing length right
that's what we do in hosting channel but
of course this assumes that the
exponential moments exist they're finite
for all lambda well they don't have to
be for all lambda but they must be at
least for the minimizing one minimizing
lambda that means right otherwise this
doesn't make sense now here is a I mean
it works very well for Bernoulli random
variables we often see this proof of
course the upper bound on the
exponential moment for Bernoulli's
follows just from the absolute bound
each of the exercise is absolutely
bounded by one and it gives you bounce
on the exponential moment I can play
around with calculus and get the best
bang so should this be all that we learn
or teach I'm going to suggest perhaps
not I'm going to look at let's look at
some distributions and data science or
any-any feel alright Gaussian of course
comes all over the place Gaussian
density does have all exponential
moments because you have x squared
fall-off there and e to the lambda X is
fine right for any positive lambda
exponential moments for positive
negative X maybe you have that Caesar
normalizing constant here already
not all exponential moments exist if
lambda is much greater than 1 you get
into trouble right things blow up if
lambda is small enough things exist so
you have to be careful about the
minimizing lambda but indeed we all know
that in modern data one band is around
this phrase a lot that power law
distributions do ok so power law means
the Kate or the power law for example I
mean this is not the only there are
generalizations but you have a
normalizing constant divided by X to the
K for X greater than 1 certainly no
exponential moment exists but even of
course the k plus k minus first and
higher moments already blow up right the
interval is infinite so you cannot apply
the moment generating function method
that i showed you or the bernstein
method it's
all that I showed you the lost life
right you go do something else now what
we do I want to put up one more
high-speed is a square a standard normal
here's some exponential moments exist
but not all and the space rate is used
in a lot of things in particular a
little bit later I'll show you Johnson
Lyndon throws a recap Johnson Linda's
throws and the proof uses the fact that
sums of Chi squares are concentrated so
what do we do we know in a lecture or a
course often is whenever they encounter
one of these we go and by hand prove
each one individually right what I would
like to tell you is that there's one
general simple concentration inequality
and all these will be corollaries again
I don't think this is you although I
don't have a reference but I mean I'll
give you a proof
I'm the idea is just simply go back to
classical good old finite moments finite
moments means Kate moment for some fixed
K is from moment generating functions
historically in probability of course
finite moments were around before
perhaps the exponential moment of the
bernstein method but the bernstein
method is so beautiful because
exponential factors nicely that it
captured all the attention and perhaps
one doesn't see so many proofs based on
finite moments but they are certainly
classical so here's you see one and I
just want to recap before I do that if R
is an even positive integer the finite
moment method if you will just says that
the probability that X is X has mean 0
greater than a is bounded by this this
is just Markov inequality apply to the
non-negative random variable X to the
off and then we need only prove upper
bounds on e expected value of x so there
are the odd moments and the nice thing
is it exists more often than the
exponential moment so as a plug for
using finite moments in in teaching it
it will be you'll be good to do that
just because all of these don't have to
be proven separately and so I'm going to
state one particular theorem and this
theorem does imply everything that you
want
and it's fairly simple to state and I'll
give you some intuition the hypothesis
is these are independent means zero that
some the variances of Sigma i screen and
the sum of the variances is the variance
of X of course right your Sigma square
is some positive integer I'm going to be
the last moments and there's a bun the
the thing I'll show you here does not
work for very large deviations as indeed
testing Chernov also has to be modified
the quadratic fall-off doesn't work for
large deviation and I'm going to assume
something that looks strange the
expected value of the art moment the arc
moment of individual X I is that most
variants time to R factorial this app
our factorial is in a sense the best you
can put there I won't argue that but
I'll argue that things work with our
factorial and the conclusion which I
will interpret verbally in a few minutes
give me what may look strange first but
let me just tell you the conclusion has
the power of R is all over 2 that's
important and the power of the standard
deviation Sigma is Sigma to the R which
is natural correct scaling that's a
conclusion and this is true for up to
the 8th moment if you assume as moment
bounce to start with you can't expect
more than that so I will interpret this
verbally in a minute but first okay that
implies the usual bounds you see that
probability is greater than a is a
squared over Sigma squared Sigma is the
variance and a squared over constant
times Sigma split is what you would get
if you are a Gaussian right and central
limit theorem tells you that's what
you're reading so here's an
interpretation that be good to remember
this strange-looking quantity is just a
moments of the Gaussian for the correct
variance if you take a Gaussian with
variance Sigma squared the moments look
like that all moments are bounded there
and they look like that so a verbal
statement of this that's good to
remember and it's natural is that if X
has sub Gaussian moments so the
conclusion is X s sub Gaussian moments
with variance Sigma squared Gaussian I
just mean that the C is
from this this see is not necessarily
tool you can get better constants here
so again it's what you would sort of
expect from central limit theorem right
that sums of independent random
variables
you should get Gaussian density at the
end and this says that you get Gaussian
moments you don't have all moments so
you don't get Gaussian density but you
need calcium oh yeah there's a
literature word people talk about sub
Gaussian sand sub exponential random
variables is the the difference here is
I'm only assuming finite number of
moments and I only can conclude
something about finite sub Gaussian
people mean the distribution the density
is e to the minus x squared over R sub
you see I just mean the moment source of
Gaussian yet so there's a Gaussian is
the entire distribution
okay that's anyway not true for
Bernoulli's for Bernoulli's when you
have large deviations you don't have
exponential quadratic exponential fall
yeah so it is true that it doesn't work
for very large very large deviations
right that's right there is a
modification that it does work what this
is a simple proof and simple statement
I'm in fact hosting channel is often
stated with only bounded deviation so as
I said I mean this this this is good old
moment method and should be folklore
except I haven't found a reference
reference I haven't looked very in a
very detailed manner I'll give you a
proof I mean this proof is short and
teachable as short as lefting Chernov
basically so only after their moment
burn but I assumed and okay so I'm going
to do one slide of a proof idea and a
couple of slides of the proof bear with
me if you don't want to hear it you can
close your eyes you'll come back to
something
it says died actually no in the slide
you'll see what okay something is I'm
allowed to do in a boot camp assuming a
simple
so you do so this is just to demonstrate
that look using moments is no more sweat
perhaps than using exponential moments
right so you do a multinomial expansion
of this so that's just our choose r1
through RN these are the exponents of
the exercise and you get that right one
first K again all these proofs this is
not just peculiar to this proof yes
terms where one of the X is raised to
the first power go away because they
expected value V DX is zero
they all odd powers don't go away you
can if the if the if the X is symmetric
all our powers will go away the proof is
even simpler but now at least the first
power goes away so they're left with at
most R over two non zero or I each at
least two and so I we take those terms
and I conveniently put an hour I
factorial in the bound in the hypothesis
so that cancels out and now you have to
worry about the combinatoric here a bit
that the proof actually has mostly
combinatory X as opposed to the
Bernstein method the number of r1
through RN which have support a
particular set of non zeros of
cardinality T the number of those only
depends on T which is by symmetry so we
reduced to the same coefficient for each
T of cardinality T we sum over all sets
of this thing product of this thing and
this is again I said another key idea
but this is really a bread and butter of
combinatorics if you are using
generating functions for instance you
seen this this is less than or equal to
that you can just get that that gives
you the proof this is the proof outline
the details again basically just going
through the outline one more time I'm
going to use the fact that's a bootcamp
to dwell on something simple as I said
sorry if I were to bore some of you you
close your eyes right so so I expanded
this I should mention that we are using
independence of course to say that it's
a product of the expectations
right and this use is the same as moment
generating function but there are all
sorts of product
all right on negative and some to all if
any are a is one advantages that we saw
that there are most are over two terms
and the all the all the association of
brackets with terms happens in this
permutation coefficient right then we
get
I'm just running over the same proof
again then we get this the art this is
just not and the are a factorial and
this cancel out and then we group terms
by the number of nonzero RI which we
call T and let t be the support then you
get that R of T is the number of RI
which have support team support T and
the sum is all well symmetry R of T
depends only on the cardinality and not
on T and a little comment or expound
stat and so we can move that term out
and you get the simple sum over all T
and that is at most that we said that
now I'll tell you why that's because if
I expand multinomial II this thing all
the kinetics and the multinomial
expansions then for each support T
exactly this term appears 3 factorial
times there are other terms where Sigma
is higher powers occur but we don't get
they are positive higher moments but
just a second expression there why did
we get sorry
the only the Sigma I squared but there
is a teeth power so you do end up doing
higher moments right but we had bounded
higher moments by semi square
and that turns out pickin me
and the little calculus says that the ro
t term dominates and therefore you you
get that and then you get used telling
to witness I don't I don't have to
remember everything but please remember
that we got Gaussian mom is the same as
a Gaussian hosting channel follows in
this form as somebody raised a question
for larger deviations this is not the
case right for epsilon in 0 and 115
cannot has an epsilon squared there that
follows right why is that that's proved
by showing that the hypothesis is
satisfied but no lis random variables in
fact it's set up for Bernoulli random
variables if X Y is 1 with probability P
I the variance is roughly P I
it's there's 1 minus P I put okay and
for any our expected value of x to the R
is P I so we don't need the R factorial
term Gaussian annulus theorem this is
going to be important for johnson eanes
ross again a senator and again in a
course or something one gets to the
stays over I can prove this behind of
course you can but this follows from
this right so if you have independent
random variables normal 0 1 and you take
the sum of squares in the square root
the length of the vector now if you have
n of these this length squared should be
concentrated around and and length
should be concentrated around root N and
this says that it doesn't deviate too
much from what it should be
and I the the what this says is that
most of the mass of the Gaussian lies on
an annulus of constant weight I don't
radius root n okay that's why I called
it Gaussian Angeles theorem the annulus
ice is different for different
distributions for uniform on a sphere
it's a different way but this is
gaussians here for oh i say that if you
have uniform density on the ball the
annulus is small as 1 over m but for
gaussians it's 1 over root n right
that's the ratio and the proof is not by
direct calculation we can get this here
you use our factorial or you have to
find the moment and the C may be too
high but it can be made small enough and
we'll see that we'll use this for the
johnson-luna software right exponential
and power law I didn't write this down
unfortunately power law well roughly
speaking
if X I or distributed okay Kate power
and X is the sum the probability that X
minus the expected value exceed certain
number of standard deviations of the sum
this is what you expect but not for very
logic
slight excuse me I'm sorry I
so I want a squid or a sigma squid not
exponential
I have only K minus two order
because I don't have higher moments I so
I have only K minus 2 over 2 that also
follows you just have to compute the
moments and here use the fact that only
some number of some moment occurs that
sort of exponential you can I'm going to
us a different topic now basically new
topic is a dimensional reduction you'll
see john salinas frost and then SVT
they're both dimension reductions right
so rodney dolphins represented as
vectors in high dimensional space one
dimension for feature if you have
feature vectors right we this is not our
job to represent to select features and
represent we assume this has been done
data science only worries about it as
the vectors are presented will say this
has been done and only deal with high
dimensional vectors it will be nice if
we can reduce the number of dimensions
so the overt aim is to improve
efficiency but there are other things
that is useful for right now we look at
dimension reduction as a way of getting
more efficient algorithms because a
number of dimensions goes down so there
are two really main methods of dimension
reduction one is random projection like
a lot johnson-luna sprouts and other
things
this is oblivious to the data so the
projection is independent of what the
data is and will see and you know
Johnson's of Salem it preserves every
length every length of a vector wrote
for him in to relative error epsilon but
you generally cannot be the epsilon
about a constant if you want to go
better than that the dimension of the
projection will become very hard right
that's the usual use so it's used
extensively in theory because of a
because every vector you can show the
length is preserved
but being is a bottleneck for use in
practice because sometimes or quite
often you might want an epsilon much
smaller than a constant for example in
theory we are happy with having one plus
epsilon times the expectation so we are
making an error of f1
thanks expectation in practice you want
to make an error commensurate with the
standard deviation which may be much
smaller than the expectation that's then
then this is not useful right so our
principal component analysis or SVD that
is a property that projection length
behaves well often better than this much
error but only when averaged over all
data some data points can project to
something quite well quite bad with
random projection everybody behaves
nicely every individual thing behaves
nicely but here that's not soil average
the behavior is often better now the
theoretical use of principal component
analysis is not too many things we'll
see
Gaussian mixture models they are used
there but here is a dichotomy that's
present in data science as a whole I
mean it's arguable you might debate that
but in theory we use random projections
a lot because we can prove theorem says
every projection is bounded in practice
perhaps I would say arguably SVD is used
more right because you gain an advantage
on average which is better
also SVD is what what you can call data
where the projection depends on the data
and in practice I guess people like to
use the data to figure out what to do
rather than not use the data to figure
out what they do but I mean it's just
one one of 10 also controversial
statements I need to make in a talk
right or something but I don't know
maybe address coming but what we'll see
both right we'll see johnson-luna
Strauss as well as principle component
analysis I mean if you want to make any
common first enough if you want to make
any comments you are welcome to and also
get a water break
that's a good question I think I don't
know many examples where they're both
used or it that is to say at the moment
I can't think of any but but yeah maybe
others can I mean I don't know
yeah it would be nice to combine them so
it's often faster to do with the RAM
projections first and then do CF works
okay that's so I should say that even in
doing SVD will see randomized algorithms
and later David and Ken will talk about
perhaps subspace embeddings which have
the flavor of random projection so maybe
that combines both in some way
okay length preserving protection so we
want to learn them length preserving
protection from D space so much smaller
dimensional space so we'd like a matrix
P random so that for every vector V the
length of P V is approximately the
length of V I like to draw your
attention to one thing here which is
familiar in the back of your minds
perhaps but the placement of the
quantifier here is important so I put a
for all V in front of the probability
that means for each individual Vedas as
the probability right if you want to say
this for many of these you have to take
the Union bound and you have to pay it
probability right that's good to
remember this is a contrast to I mean
for example we see dimensional an
empirical process theory where we would
be inside the brackets we cannot put V
inside the brackets here we'll see okay
number one number two a little bit in in
further talks you will see that it's
useful actually not to require K to be
much smaller than T and then in fact you
can move this inside and one example of
that would be subspace embeddings again
which which you'll see later press so
what happens if I place it inside it's
not true right
if the quantifier is inside K is less
than D there's always a vector V which
is an announced pace of P and P v-0
director is non zero so of course this
is false so you cannot move it inside
the other thing to remember about random
predictions is they do not preserve dot
products so some occasions one would
like to all give dot products are
preserved but for that you cannot use
this dimensional reaction so that can be
an issue so original projection
projected to a random K dimensional
subspace says Johnson in this phrase in
terms of matrices P will be a random K
by D matrix with orthonormal rows while
picking such a random matrix because you
have to make them all to normal there's
dependents it's difficult also arguing
with them is difficult
in fact the argument will give which is
based on a paper of the scope Tangle
Teezer reference there is based on
gaussian vectors rather than uniform
random subspace of dimension K so we
pick iid K vectors each with
distribution normal zero identity this
identity here is the variance covariance
matrix these are my vectors picked with
standard Gaussian in each coordinate
right that's what I do 2d says and we
project will use the following
projection simply just take the dot
product with each of the use in the
beach for C projecting to a random k
dimensional space had dependence because
the vectors were orthogonal right and so
you have to project against each one but
now these are not these are just
independent random vectors will prove
that with high probability that's true
and the root K is natural there's a root
K is just a constant factor so you can
factor it out root K is natural because
you are going
because these these are of length root
cane the V you eyes are of length I'm
sorry
the you guys are of length root n but
there are K of them that's why through
so wide okay that's that now you got so
as you know for a fixed vector V V dot
uses some of independent random variable
so it's just fake it's also Gaussian
distributed with with this variance
right and so here's that theorem and the
proof this line of proof is due to good
angle
so f is a projection that you took dot
product with K different Gaussian
vectors there's a constant C so I said
for epsilon between 0 and 1 again not
true very very large epsilon the
difference between the projected length
and this a scaling factor and the real
length is not very big squid only if
epsilon spins there on 1 and the
probability is taken over all random
draws of you I used to construct F and
remark V is not random if it is very
nearly right very useful for everything
and it follows from the gaussian analyst
theorem because the DF scored names a
Gaussian right independent Gaussian and
it's length then is the common some of
Chi squares right so that we use that
there on them
now if you want to apply it to a lot of
vectors and I'm going to go over this a
little bit in a lot of context the
number of vectors you apply it is
polynomial but not always you have to be
a little careful if you want to apply to
a lot of actors you do the Union bound
so again epsilon is this and the
projected dimension is high enough
compared to the number of points but
only logarithmic Li we want to be in is
any set of endpoints then the
probability that the difference of the
projections is very different from the
difference of the vectors is small so
every pairwise distance is precise and
that's just by Union bound so that fall
is simply from Jeremiah there's nothing
nothing to do that
okay I'm going to show you an example
where it automatically applies an
example where it doesn't so we'll see
the reasons for that so yeah given
endpoints NRT we want to partition into
K parts so that we minimize the sum of
squared distances of the points for the
nearest cluster Center this is the
k-means clustering problem they're all
familiar with that cluster Center is the
mean of the cluster that's true for
k-means only right the correct cluster
Center is just the average of the
centroid of the points you have to prove
that that's not true for the criteria so
find the best so you projected as many
dimensions find the best clustering in
the projection will this do
since all distances are preserved to 1
plus or minus Epsilon it should do what
we need to be careful how many distances
need to reserve right crudely the number
of possible cluster centers could be
there will be two to the impossible
subsets each could have a cluster Center
right and if you have to apply the Union
bound to that that's not so good there's
too many luckily for any end point sum
of squared distances the mean is
expressible in terms of the sum of
pairwise distances so it's enough to
preserve all pairwise distances
okay means could everything can be
expressed in terms of pairwise distances
and there aren't too many of those there
are polynomial number of those here's
some food for thought Robert K median
clustering which is another clustering
criterion in that criterion you minimize
the sum of distances to the cluster
centers now the cluster centers can be
arbitrary points so it's unclear that
you can apply JL right because the
number of candidate distances to
preserve is exponential or even infinite
so I actually um when I was making these
flights I said people will ask me if I
know
so like any nobody did so if it can be
applied but I don't know somebody knows
the answer I mean you can you apply a
random projection to K median I don't
know yeah you have to be careful
usually in TCS k median is stated as
cluster Center must be one of the data
points usually in data science it's not
necessary k-means the cluster centers of
centroids of clusters which need not be
data points if you assume cluster Center
there be data points of course then
there aren't so many candidates but if
you allow arbitrary points in space then
then that argument doesn't work
okay now I want to show you a central
and essential problem with Johnson
Lyndon Strauss why it doesn't work in
certain situations and why we'll see
later SVD and PCA do work so standard
mnemonic in statistics is means
separated by 6 or 10 standard deviations
ok let's say we want to be a little more
general soul means separated by order 1
standard deviations I want to this is
going to be a bit of a theme for a few
slides so it's good to remember so let's
say I'm given samples from an equal
mixture of two gaussians normal zero
identity this is in high dimensional
space right and the other one the mean
is mu where the length of the separation
between the means is constant okay so
now the standard deviation is constant
in each direction right device variance
covariance matrix and divisions constant
in each direction and I'm assuming the
means are separated by a constant number
of sanitary and the question is to learn
what's mu or learn the two didn't do
Gaussian densities from samples so I
should draw a picture change
you gonna draw them very close and I'm
given samples from this Gaussian and we
saw that they lie in an small annulus
I'm samples from this Gaussian or I
should have drawn them different color
but your job is to use separate them
your job is to separate them and
therefore learn this
no say is a problem with Johnson Lyndon
Scott's random projection is no good
because epsilon relative error is too
high
why is that because the variance in each
direction is one the distance squared of
this is about DS a dimensional the
overall variance is d so points lie at
distance about D it seems square from
the center however if I take this point
and take its distance to the wrong
center this distance squared is V this
distance squared is constant and when
your random almost all angles are 90
degrees this I can prove it but these
two will be orthogonal essentially and
therefore that distance squared will be
D plus simple
these big if I make epsilon error C is
lost so in fact what what this is this
is a very good example to remember I
sort of use this in all talks it's a
trivial example but it's good to have in
mind if I do
two means clustering with relative
epsilon which is standard in TCS you can
miss cluster every point and it's still
valid still the objective function is
one bit
why is that because miss passing only
costs you see and epsilon error loves
the epsilon D that's a huge error that's
a lot so two means clustering is no good
I suppose I was trying to draw this
picture and I'm sorry I didn't draw that
so what is good for this so let's see
what is good for this right this is good
for that so I I will come back to why
that's good for this but right now we
want to see we want to see an intro to
singular value decomposition that's good
in for those who know I mean many of you
already know perhaps right if I do SVD
there's a very nice result of and pollen
wrong that the SPD subspace gives you
this you see this line joining the
center
if I now project the whole thing to the
line joining the centers then the
standard deviation is still one
gaussians projections give you the same
standard deviation as as spherical
capsules right now as the whole thing
Stanley visions still one they are
separated by C so the points look like
this right and that's easy to separate
you need an extra log factor if you want
to get everybody right but it needs you
to separate for why did I can find this
I can find the space-time by the
center's and the big point is that that
is actually there sweetie subspace
you'll see that but first for that I
have to recap for the 3d is and perhaps
here y'all
I mean most of you know from your linear
algebra or a 3d is but here's a view
which is also just obvious but is a view
that's based on data if you will of
singular value decomposition we have n
points in D space each row each data
point is a row of the data matrix and
SVD is Jess precisely is the best fit k
dimensional subspace for a for the data
so ya bunch of data it's a best fit k
dimensional subspace that's fit in the
sense of minimum sum of squared
perpendicular distances so another
picture
these or points in space right and so
then I take if I want this is K equals
two if I want the best plane I do insist
on subspaces so they have to pass
through the origin okay bear with me on
that will will fix that in a minute
and you take each point and take the
perpendicular distance square eight and
sum the squares are very important in in
all of this right square it and some and
minimize that over all three that is the
definition of SVD a that I want to use
usual definitions or in terms of metric
factorizations or what have you but this
is a natural one for data I mean it it
follows essentially from all that we
know that this to be true so equalent
lee we can take the maximum sum of
squares of the lengths of the projection
of data points into the subspace here's
a little picture so here's data point AI
i data point here is a subspace which is
a candidate for best fit let's say i
could have taken some of space of these
i minimized or i could have taken some
of squares of these and nice
with other sets the sum of those two is
a constant so we maximize the sum of
squares squares are the projections onto
the subspace that's a definition of SVD
mice so this is just saying what I said
in words minimizing some more distance
Quaid's of the projection every
distances is the same as maximizing yeah
so you have to forget you're just a
little site
you have to forget what least squares
fit in calculus meant there are only two
coordinates right and you didn't take
the perpendicular distance you took the
vertical distance right so anyway so it
does different from least squares fit in
calculus right now we say these squares
as well as SVD we backtrack least
squares fit in calculus doesn't have to
pass through the origin right depends on
all the data lies but in the SVD case we
require the subspace so it had to pass
through the origin but that actually is
no loss of generality see later I'm not
going to show you that but you can prove
that the best fit of fine subspace if I
don't insist on the origin being in it
affine subspace is the one that passes
through the centroid of the data this is
just like the k-means proof and
therefore we can translate we can find
the centroid in the beginning translate
to make it zero then there's no loss of
generality we're getting the best
alliance of this case again why differ
from whispers yeah okay good point let's
see
so what do you do least-squares is you
know a bunch of points at least place is
just two argument so I can draw it in
the plane I want the line that best fits
right but how do I measure the error I
take this vertical distance that's so
this is the function of X I and this is
King give an argument so I take Y I
minus FXI I do not take the distance
perpendicular to the subspace which is
what I would do here in SVD that's all
thing this is the same definition that's
one higher division or something
not sure I don't see how to fit it I
mean yeah possible
we don't see how to fit it into one
so we actually can save the best I find
best fit affine subspace rather than
okay so the other point we want we want
to recap about SVD is it is probably and
this is arguable it's probably the
earliest proven greedy algorithm
actually working and a very nice proof
of course I won't go through the proof
but here's here's what the statement is
here is a greedy algorithm for finding
the best fit ten dimensional subspace to
the data plus find the best fit one
dimensional subspace touches the line
through the origin find the best fit
line that's sort of am innocent of least
squares except it's measured differently
right you find the best fit line then
the best fit line second time you do the
best fit line through the origin
perpendicular to the first at the ID
step you find the best fit line
perpendicular to I minus one lines you
found so far you keep going until rank
of a is easy to see that after rank of a
it's all zero and the big theorem oh I
mean its classical theorem and again
with a nice proof is that for every I
the subspace spanned by the first five
actors so found is the best Vidya
dimensional subspace today
so greedy works right and it sort of
saying I haven't told you how to find
the best way one-dimensional subject I
won't tell you many methods right the
numerical answers has devoted a lot of
time and effort to developing good
methods to do that but that's enough to
do it Marshall
so arguably the earliest proven greedy
algorithm of course I think the other
greedy algorithms have been suggested
before this but in terms of proving that
it works and gives you the correct
answer perhaps this is I mean this
probably predates certainly a spanning
tree and so I mean yeah all break all
hell breaks loose if we don't have write
l2 and all if we don't have the square
so if I measured if I said best fit I
measure the distance rather than the
squared distance of data points
perpendicular distance to the hyperplane
no none of this works right everything
is dependent on the square even
Pythagoras depending on the space it's
good
so I seem to come to the end of the
first lecture now I can go over the
entire second lecture already or I if
you have questions or or we can take a
little longer break whichever
for somebody to a question so that we
can do something
people do like faces and others okay
there's some literature on other
distance measures for instance for
clustering people have certainly
considered other norms and done stuff I
mean there's nothing as beautiful as
being algebra for other norms but some
stuff is there and you can ask similar
questions for multi remittances and in
fact some of this well we'll see if some
of this will extend only briefly mention
that
the problem the solution is not so far
away okay that's a good question so I
think your question is reminiscent of
compressed sensing right where you we
would like to minimize L infinity norm
which is far not possible instead you do
l1 and show that under some conditions
that works okay so I imagine yes if you
had assumptions as strong as compress
sensing or a peon then it is possibly
true that l2 and l1 are not so different
right possible
I don't know proofs of that so it's
something that people haven't sat down
and worked out unless somebody has
something to say about that
so what the assumptions are pretty
strong I will go over what the
assumptions are for instance for
comprehensive but they they are strong
so under those assumptions you can
detail infinity and l1 work the same way
sort of
yeah so this actually computes the best
bit a subspace market just compute the
distance oh I see okay so that's a good
question so in terminology here you may
want to compute only the singular values
rather than the singular vectors also it
is a bit easier numerically because it's
saying singular values are more stable
than singular vectors I've seen the
vectors are much more dependent on
perturbations but I don't know any
direct algorithmic advantage people have
taken of that to compute just missing a
value that you can use subspace
embedding these we have rectangular
matrices so you can use randomized
methods that will actually you can use
all the random so okay sorry a David is
right so we can use randomized
algorithms we'll see not only in this
talk but through this several box
and those give you singular values to
some accuracy they don't give you
singular vectors so K singular vectors
are notoriously discontinuous when there
are ties right we're a singular values a
continuous always so they give you
single values but they don't give you a
singular vectors because there may be
sharp this kind
it's good I made the talk short because
we got a lot of more questions then so
when we come back I'm going to carry on
with well let me maybe I'll do I'm
tempted to do five minutes of this
because then we'll be more relaxed at
the other end over then I pull up the
file which is actually I won't do that
so when we come back we'll do we'll do a
sweetie some randomized algorithms for
linear algebra and I want to briefly
touch upon Markov chains where I'll
state the fundamental theorem as well as
rapid mixing with sort of again unusual
proofs different proofs more
probabilistic proves perhaps then what
one uses normally if you're familiar
with that but I'll make it from first
principles so it'll be easy to follow
[Applause]